-Welcome back. Jamie Dornan
is joining us right here.
We're talking about
his new movie, "Belfast."
You know, there was
a big premiere
for "Belfast" in Belfast.
-Yep.
-What was that like?
-Listen. It was one of
the best nights of my life.
It was -- I -- I felt like
vomiting for the whole day.
Like, I have never --
I get nervous
before kind of everything --
this.
Everything -- Even this.
-Yeah.
-No, I really get, like,
a sick feeling in my stomach
when you are about to put
something out there like that.
But particularly for the --
doing it for the people of home,
you know.
This -- This movie
means so much to them.
-Was there family and friends
there?
-We have family and some
of my best mates there.
1,400, you know, people
from Belfast,
so it was a special night.
-Wow.
-Yeah, it was class. Yeah.
-I got to say the cast
was amazing and the chemistry.
But that little --
the little kid.
-Oh. Stop.
-What -- Jude Hill.
-Yeah. Jude Hill.
He's incredible. He's only --
-It's got to be his first.
-It's his first ever.
And I think -- Yeah, he -- he'd
done a lot of Irish dancing.
That was only the sort of
performative thing
that he'd done,
and he just steals every scene,
as you -- as you've noticed.
-He's so --
-Incredible.
His face, man. His face.
-Cute. Everything about him.
You're like, "Oh, my gosh."
Did he love it?
-And he's really cheeky.
He's really cheeky.
-He is, right?
-Yeah.
-But I keep telling him
to embrace it.
You need that
to get through life, I think.
-Exactly right.
Yeah, you got to be --
You got to be silly, man.
Absolutely. Yeah.
And then you have Judi Dench.
-Yeah.
-Hitting a homer.
-Like she wouldn't.
But I mean --
-No. I know.
Well, when I signed on,
it was only Judi Dench attached
at that point.
I was like, "I don't need
to read the script.
Like, I'm doing it.
I don't care."
-Yeah.
Yeah, no matter what it is.
-I don't care what I'm doing in
a Judi Dench film, but, like --
-"But I'm doing it."
-If I'm playing her son,
I'm definitely doing it.
-What a great look she had, too.
-Incredible.
-They did a great job --
hair and makeup.
-Yeah, she is amazing.
-Is she just awesome
to be around?
-Ciarán Hinds, who plays my dad
in it, he sums her up perfectly.
He says she's a rebel.
She does --
She has this, like, rebellious,
like, cheeky, like, mischievous
side to her,
And she's, like, 87, Judi.
-And she just --
she comes ready to play.
You know,
it's very fun to be around.
-I feel like I would
just ask her any question
just to have her
tell me something.
Be like, "Yeah,
I'm going to have coffee.
Should I put anything in it?
What do you think, Judi?"
-She will never steer you
the wrong way.
-Right?
-No, no.
-She won't.
-She's incredible.
Incredible woman.
-Class. Class act.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here is Jamie Dornan
in "Belfast."
Take a look at this.
-These boys are suffering.
I don't think we've got
till Easter.
[ Thunder rumbles ]
I don't think you and me
have got till Easter, either.
-I'll come home.
We'll fight this together.
-Kids the same age as ours
are getting killed
or in the quarter.
-We'll -- We'll be careful.
-You can't be with them
24 hours a day.
You can't take away
their childhood either.
-[ Cheers and applause ]
-Jamie Dornan, everybody.
"Belfast" is in select theaters
and on demand now.